in today's Aid on your side we've been
reporting on the increase in catalytic
converter thefts over the past year and
tonight we show you just how quickly it
can happen which vehicles in our state
are most susceptible and what you can do
to protect your car
fax estimates more than 153 000 Vehicles
had their catalytic converters stolen
across the U.S last year in Las Vegas
metro police report more than 2 800
thefts they literally just saw it off
yeah take it yeah yep absolutely
recently thieves in Las Vegas took off
with the precious metal from the 27
footlong famous Wienermobile these
thieves are very Brazen they are hitting
dealership Lots at night they're hitting
apartment complex parking lots at night
they're even stealing in broad daylight
Patrick Olson is the editor-in-chief at
Carfax crunching the numbers on the most
targeted vehicles for catalytic
converters as well as sharing this video
with us
on just how quickly someone can steal a
catalytic converter we had an expert uh
go after a Nissan Frontier truck that we
had and he was able to remove the entire
Cadillac converter in 66 seconds 66
seconds and while one will fetch between
50 bucks and several hundred it's really
about the precious rear Metals inside
whose values have all spiked here's a
look at the top 10 most targeted
vehicles for our state largely the same
popular models and while pickup trucks
make them an easier Target because they
sit up a bit higher thieves also like
hybrids like the Toyota Prius because
the metals can be sold for even more
platinum and Palladium are going for
about a thousand bucks an ounce on
trading markets rhodium is going for ten
thousand dollars an ounce and so that
makes it a really attractive Target for
thieves
and here's what you can do to protect
your vehicle you want to make sure to
park in well-lit areas close to public
entrances regularly move your car spot
or use a closed garage install an
anti-theft device motion sensitive
lights cameras in your parking area and
most important as he says comprehensive
insurance consider it as liability
insurance does not cover a catalytic
converter theft